VICTOR BLACKWELL: This
is personal for me.
Congressman Elijah Cummings,
as my mother puts it,
is one of the people
who gives you keys.
He's given me keys at different
points throughout my life.
For most of my life, he was the
representative of my community,
home district, Maryland 7.
And I first met
Congressman Cummings
when I was 16 years old.
He had started this new youth
program, Elijah Cummings Youth
Program in Israel, where a few
students were chosen to travel
to Israel for close
to a month to learn
about the culture and religion.
At the airport, he showed up to
say goodbye and wish us well.
And I remember
something he said.
He said, open yourself up.
Make the possibility.
Create the possibility
of learning,
meeting someone, thinking of
things in a different way.
I've kept that.
That's one of those little keys.
Congressman Cummings
was also the speaker
at my high school graduation.
And he told his story of his
personal and professional life.
And I remember him saying,
never let anyone define you.
He said that so many times.
ELIJAH CUMMINGS: Don't let
them take away your hope.
I don't care who they are.
And let no one
define you-- no one.
VICTOR BLACKWELL: Now,
I'm sitting there as,
at that point, a 17-year-old
who wanted to be on television,
to be a TV journalist.
There was nobody on
television with my build.
I didn't know any
openly gay television
reporters or anchors.
But 20 years into
this business now,
that key from
Congressman Cummings--
never let anyone define you--
has led me to this point.
Thank you.
In 2017, I was
invited back to be
part of the celebration
of 20 years of the Elijah
Cummings Youth Program.
The congressman
recorded a video.
And to hear him speak about
us, to speak about me in a way,
I knew that this was
a personal investment.
ELIJAH CUMMINGS: And
Victor, your ears
should be burning because
there's not a week that goes
by that I don't talk about
you and how proud I am to know
that a young man who
grew up in a neighborhood
similar to the one I live in now
has gone on to be a CNN anchor.
VICTOR BLACKWELL: In 2019, when
the former president tweeted
that Congressman Cummings
district, my hometown,
was a "rat-infested place where
no human would want to live,"
that was personal.
It was offensive.
And all of Baltimore
was outraged by that.
ELIJAH CUMMINGS: Do
not just criticize us,
but come to Baltimore,
and I promise you,
you will be welcome.
VICTOR BLACKWELL: Another key--
another key from the
congressman in the way
that he responded
to that vitriol
with grace and hospitality.
Congressman Cummings died
just a few months after that.
Some of those keys that
opened a lot of doors
and helped me throughout my life
are the ones that Congressman
Cummings gave me.
And I think a lot of people
have received those keys.
- (SINGING) I'm gonna
let it shine, let it--